one day before the opening of the Sochi
Olympics and anticipation is high the
Olympic torch relays in the final
stretch after a four-month journey
across Russia athletes are making their
qualifying runs while fans gather many
of those here today are Russians initial
boom but is we support Russia because
Russia will be the champion and will
receive the most medals go Russia Russia
spit up the games are a gigantic
logistical challenge entire towns with
hotels and streets as well as the actual
athletic facilities have been built in a
very short time that's contributed to
the record price tag for the games
security has been a concern as well
40,000 police officers have been
deployed and airborne surveillance
cameras patrol the skies officials say
they're confident visitors will be safe
should I would like to repeat that the
level of security in the city of Sochi
is no worse than in New York London
Washington or Boston London Russian
Clooney Lou boost protesters have also
been excluded from the Olympic Park this
official protest zone is 18 kilometers
from the olympic games the games have
been criticized as a propaganda
opportunity for the government at a time
when human rights are under attack in
Russia especially gay rights United
Nations secretary-general ban ki-moon
addressed the issue in his speech to the
Olympic Committee seen here we must all
raise our voices against attacks or
lesbians gays bisexual transgender or
intersex people we must oppose the
arrest imprisonment and discriminatory
restrictions they face that doesn't seem
to have dampened spirits in Sochi dozens
of heads of state are scheduled to
attend the opening ceremonies on Friday
as the build-up to the 17 day
extravaganza continues